I want to talk about this comment
particularly where it says that not all men can provide this.
Cause that opens up a bigger conversation.
So, yes, I am immensely blessed the property we have, um,
with our situation, etcetera.
That being said, though,
yeah, it's true,
not all men are gonna be able to provide.
Which is why it is so important to be very choosey
and picky with who you marry.
Marriage is not something to take lightly.
It is not just a piece of paper.
It is very, very serious.
I need to be looking at character of a man who wants to provide.
If you wanna be a chadwave, um,
homemaker, stay at home mom,
you're gonna need a man who wants to provide that lifestyle to you.
I do think there is a lot of red flags to look for in men.
Not just the emotional dating side of things,
but also financial red flags on how do.
How good are they with their money?
So if you get past all that
and you find a man that you really love and adore,
and you've gotten to know him well enough to marry him,
then if you cannot provide for you financially
right off the bat when you get married,
that is totally okay.
And this is my reasoning.
When you start out,
you're not gonna be where you wanna be 30 years down the line.
And I feel like a lot of people go Into marriage, thinking, oh,
I'm gonna have this right away.
But a lot of times,
like when you first get married,
it's. It's a lot of working together,
grinding it out together,
um, building the life you want together to get where you wanna be.
And that might not be staying home right off the bat.
And it may look like a lot of years of hard work,
penny pinching,
etcetera, to actually be able to stay home.
That's why it's so great to be a help meet to a husband,
because it doesn't always just look like being home.
That looks like, maybe,
how can I earn income so that we get out of this set amount of debt?
Or something like that,
that I can stay.
All in all, be very choosey with who you marry.
If they are not gonna be a provider,
if you don't see them being a provider,
um, don't marry them.